wir sehen schon mal rein
hast du schon vorgewarnt
wir führen gleich anja denke ich wie wir
schon jetzt habe ich sehr schön das
gespräch hat es gibt nur an ihnen ich
bin für immer nur schöne
uns genügt schon mal eine stunde und
brauchen wir fangen mit einer standard
frage an wie ist die lage
die lage ist
entspannt aber nicht hoffnungslos
wieso nicht auch noch zu fuß vielleicht
gerade jetzt auf promotion reisefirma
neues album match point und das ist
jetzt hier die dritte woche glaube ich
und das ist halt ganzen tag wer es nicht
kennt ganzen tag interviews
dieselben
schlechten fragen immer wieder super
neue antworten
ich habe festgestellt weil eigentlich
macht gutes interview die guten
antworten aus und nicht die schlechten
fragen und ich glaube auch ja und naja
und dann ist man dann so am ende der
woche also wenn es dann ab morgen ist es
dann erstmal so etwas pause
und dann merkt man dann eigentlich schon
wenn man entspannt sie haben auch nach
dem film da merkt man einfach angetan
hat solange man noch dabei ist und der
spannung ist dann zieht man das alles
durch und dann merkt man das schon
fühlt man sich in der mühle oder ist es
auch eine art von spielen man muss sich
ja immer wieder selber motivieren das
hat das hab ich spiele nichts zu tun das
ist ja immer für guten zweck meistens ja
und zwar für einen selbst also man das
ist wie
in dem anderen bereich auch sowohl
produkt hergestellt wird
möchte man dass es auch die menschen
mitbekommen und
und da muss man was wir tun gerade
heutzutage wo man so überflutet wird mit
informationen und werbung aller art
durch internet durch alles mögliche
muss man auch da und tun das ist was
neues gibt es denn so bei den vielen
schlechten fragen
dass man dann manchmal doch am ende des
tages etwas ich sag mal ausgeleiert ist
also wenn sie mir gar nicht behagt dann
sage ich schon also wir können sich
vorstellen die frage hierzu müssen mal
also nächste bitte aber meistens bin ich
da ganz gnädig und beantwortet ja auch
und sowohl für den fragesteller ist ja
immer zum ersten mal also was sind bei
ihnen die standard fragen wo sie lieber
nicht mehr darauf achten damit indem ich
mach da muss ich dir jetzt stellen okay
was sehen sie denn mehr musiker oder
schauspieler
wie es meinen kindern geht ob wir zu
hause ob die für mich konkurrenz sind
und so ganz schlaue fragen und
ja das sind so die die top 3
mit liszts auf die schädlichste da sind
die auch wo sie dann sagen ach lieber
nicht oder es gibt der sendung und
wenn's live ist da kann man ja dem nicht
ausweichen doch da kommen auch sondern
auch ehrlich wieso
ist die frage da fällt mir keine
kreative antworten keine neue
ich glaube nicht dass die leute das
wirklich so interessiert kann man doch
auch ganz nett machen was möchten sie
denn am liebsten gefragt werden
eigentlich gar nichts aber
naja ich nenne ich
denke wenn ich ein interview mit mir
selbst machen würde
dann würde ich mir mal überlegen was ist
ja vielleicht noch nicht gefragt worden
und so lassen und dann gibt es immer
noch irgendwelche fragen die noch nie
gestellt wird zum beispiel wie ich mit
so einem
riesentalent umgehe selbst zum genialen
talent oder wie wie wie ich es geschafft
habe so normal zu bleiben zum beispiel
ja wie gehen sie mit so einem
riesentalent um halten wir gedacht dass
das jetzt so funktioniert ganz gut ganz
gut man muss ja irgendwie man ist ja
eigentlich ein normaler mensch
jetzt kommt dieses talent dazu
wo man natürlich leicht verführt ist
oder sieht man auch in vielen andern zu
glauben man wäre etwas besonderes mit so
einem talent oder man hat mehr vorrechte
als anderen oder man möchte anders
behandelt werden und so
und sich da selbst auch mit hilfe
anderer freunde familie
diese beobachten dann wieder runter zu
gehen und zu sagen das muss man jetzt
einfach so auch als etwas ganz normales
hinnehmen für ein selbst wenn
man sich dann mal ernsthaft damit
auseinandersetzen
es ist gar nicht so einfach manchmal
weiß ich kenne es von anderen stars zum
teil gibt es ja auch ein umfeld was
einem ständig sagt wie toll man ist ja
klar ich möchte es bei mir auch so wenn
ich im restaurant ist ist voll hier gibt
es irgendwie viel platz ist natürlich
auch sehr bequem und angenehm aber der
witz dabei sind ich glaube der trick ich
hatte trick gefunden schon seit längerer
zeit man darf das nicht so ernst nehmen
alles nur man muss also wissen dass die
das machen weil ich der bin und ich will
dich so sympathisch bin oder so toll
aussehen aber es gibt ja trotzdem der
besondere fähigkeit die andere nicht
haben oder mehrere besondere fähigkeit
aber man muss halt irgendwie lernen und
damit insofern klarzukommen dass man
nicht denkt dass man deswegen auch
automatisch was besonderes ist weil alle
anderen dingen die menschen tut von
morgens bis abends macht man ja klar
aber man macht etwas mit dem man
auffällt wenn man singt da ist man kein
schreiner der zwar auch ist eine kunden
zufriedenstellen kann von den applaus
bekommt aber sie kriegen dann millionen
ich hab' ich habe das große glück den
vorteil zu haben dass ich mich nicht
viel selbstbewusstsein erzogen wurde und
aufgewachsen bin und ich glaube das ist
mit ein grund warum ich auch immer im
rampenlicht stehen wollte
und natürlich auch mit viel glück ist es
passiert dass ich
dass das eingetreten ist und jetzt hat
sich das selbstbewusstsein angefüllt und
jetzt gewachsen und aber auf ein
gesundes niveau hat sich eingependelt es
ist praktisch bei mir auf null was
vorher im minus war was bei anderen
menschen von natur aus auf null ist nah
oder mehr im positiven also im plus nach
oben und insofern ist es eigentlich
genau was mir passiert ist genau hat
genau den richtigen getroffen das heißt
sie sind im umgang mit anderen menschen
ein ganz normaler
also ich sehe das so ja und was ich so
höre von anderen immer wieder höre mit
welcher klasse für die bisher normal
geblieben dann scheint das wohl auch
tatsächlich so zu sein ist wo haben sie
ja auch momente wo
den fans oder irgendwie mitarbeiter bei
dem film über die sich blöd bin eben
sagen komm wir gehen sehr offen und ich
sage du ich trinke jetzt nichts mehr
weil das autofahren oder ich hab einfach
mag ich nicht so arrogant das kommt auch
mal vor also ganz selten und dann muss
man den leuten halt irgendwie und dann
auch mal bescheid geben und sagen wer
hier eigentlich arrogant ist und wer
sich gut benimmt das kommt auch mal vor
selten ja weil man hat es auch mit
menschen zu tun die einem anders
gegenüber treten als eben einem normalen
menschen sie haben ehrfurcht oder ja so
ist das und und da muss man aber auch
verständnis dafür haben weil ist klar
wenn ich jetzt irgendwie ein lokal
kommen und würde mit jagger am tisch
sitzen oder jack nicholson soll jemand
da wäre ich auch leicht nervösen lohn
und verwirrt und natürlich sucht man
dann irgendwie würde man das gespräch
suchen oder aufmerksamkeit versucht zu
erregen aber da ich nur in einer
ähnlichen situation weiß ich natürlich
wie blöd das ist und dass die leute den
ganzen tag haben die sowieso auf der
ganzen welt und da hätte man sich dann
schon zurück aber ich kann die leute
sehr gut verstehen und ich freue mich
auch immer das ist immer eine
bestätigung für mein dasein
wie sie den ihrer familien ihrer familie
ihre söhne sind ja quasi
dementsprechend auch ihren ihre
fußstapfen getreten was geben sie den
für tipps mit wir reden schon über die
platte auf
da wollen sie an nachgefragt werden dass
wir auch eine frage das werde ich die
haupt die einzige die richtig
interessiert hätte wo ich auch antworten
darauf habt gute butter von allerhand
vorbereitet wie war die frage noch
irgendwas erwarten wir sind mit an die
hand geben aus ihren erfahrungen weil ja
ich sag mal von der prominenz der inn en
in ähnliche fußstapfen treten wie sie
ja ich muss da gar nicht so viel
erklären und reden weil die sind mehr
damit aufgewachsen praktisch meine
einstellung zu dem ganzen und ich glaube
da haben sie sich schon das hat sich
schon ganz gut geprägt da muss man nicht
mehr viel machen ab und zu die eine oder
andere korrektur aber es hält sich in
grenzen also die
machen das ganz gute vorarbeiten das
ganz gut also ihre lieblings frage ist
die zur platte zum beispiel also wir
aber nicht nur einen haben mit einer an
und dann ja die war mal was wie haben
sie ihren stil gefunden haben sie die
platte schon mal habe ich gehört
auch einer der wenigen des logos zum
pool vorbereitet es gibt ja sparen gibt
ja heute ipods da kann man sich das
laden und dann kommen was während der
autofahrt sind etwas anders hört ist
völlig wurscht dass wir wissen worüber
wir ja er hat sich der stil wie sind sie
auf den stil gekommen ist er entstanden
den stil gab es ja schon also ich bin
mit dem stil mit dem sound ja eigentlich
aufgewachsen was heute als draußen wir
heute wieder so musik gemacht das heißt
ein retro und für mich ist ja dem titel
kann reto ich habe mich schon
aufgewachsen wie gesagt
ich wollte diesmal eine platte machen
die
handgemacht ist mit handgemachter musik
und
ganz einfach und durchsichtig ja und
nicht musik die jetzt
zugeklebt ist mit ihren arrangements und
oder
elektronischen technischen tricks
sondern ich wollte die songs live
geschrieben haben dass die auch
mit ganz wenigen mittel mit den
nötigsten musikalischen mitteln
gespielt werden und das ist das ergebnis
gefällt mir wirklich sehr gut das ist
ein platinen muss man auch öfters hören
man entdeckt immer wieder neue sachen
auch ich sogar ich werde jetzt auch
nicht jeden tag würden mal pause ist
sich auch komplizierter noch mal richtig
intensiv reihen mit kopfhörer und so
finde ich ordentlich gemacht der sie
versprüht spaß würde ich sagen auch das
noch ja also man hat das gefühl die
haben alle ziemlich viel spaß gehabt
dann aber sind es also ich bin ja jetzt
kein deutscher liedermacher der
irgendwelche botschaften hat und so was
die leute gibt und die machen auch guten
job finde ich auch alles in ordnung aber
ich mit spaß haben mich am leben vor
allem auch bei der musik das soll spaß
machen beim zuhören vor allem wenn wir
live spielen das ist der grund warum ich
eigentlich musik mache live das habe ich
jetzt die letzten sechs jahre der der
pause wo keine cd gemacht wurde sehr
viel gemacht in deutschland sehr viel
live gespielt und das zeigt einfach dass
die leute einen riesen spaß dabei haben
sogar bei regen den schauspielern können
die spaß haben das gibt es auch ist das
ein bisschen auch kontrast zu ihrem
anderen beruf wohl eher eine szene
fünfmal wiederholt wird es endlich im
kasten ist ist schon natürlich ein
bisschen was anderes weil es viel
direkter ist na also man
macht den mund auf es kommt ein ton raus
vorbildlich aber bis jetzt hat es mal
geklappt und und schon macht mit musik
und show
wenn man es denn gut und richtig macht
kommt es auch bei den leuten an und das
geht dann eben beim konzert immer hin
und her und es ist auch ich denke musik
ist auch wirklich so abgedroschen das
klingt
also diese art musik war auch immer ein
aspekt von freiheiten also wenn wenn
jemand musik macht und beim konzert ist
und und auch das zuhört dann
spürt man immer
es ist immer so ein hauch von freiheit
mit dabei eine musik befreit und wenn es
nur für den moment ist wo man es hört
oder machten was ist das für eine
freiheit die da entsteht ja das ist
einfach ein gefühl
das aber über alle grenzen hinweg geht
ja das ist
beschreiben
es spielt die zeit keine rolle mehr in
dem moment
für seine problemchen vergisst man man
gibt sich der musik hin und ist einfach
schwerelos ja das ist einfach so man
kann die musik genießen und alles wird
relativiert ja und das ist schon eine
form der freiheit finde ich und es war
natürlich der hippiezeit ganz extremen
da war er musik extrem ausdruck von
protest unabhängigkeit freiheit und
laufen ps und so und ich glaube das hat
musik tatsächlich und zwar alle arten
von musik auch volksmusik volkstümliche
musik müsse die leute glücklich macht
warum kommt das haben sie denn damals
auch schon musik gemacht als
jugendlicher ich habe schon immer musik
gemacht also ich kann zwar kein
instrument sehr gut spielen ich krieg
zwar aus alles im ton aus allen
irgendwie ton raus aber
ich
war er mit zehn jahren im kinderchor der
oper mannheim damals und hab da schon
kräftig gesungen insofern habe ich mich
dass ich hier angefangen und sonst habe
ich mich immer mein vater hat mich ein
bisschen schlagzeug gespielt und da hab
ich mir was abgeguckt und der auch
sänger war im opernchor der war
ausgebildeter opernsänger hat das im
chor aber nur als hobby gemacht und hat
aber nebenbei auch schlagzeuger
übersprühen gespielt und da wollte ich
also schon mit schlagzeug konfrontiert
und spiele das bis heute noch ganz gerne
persönlich aber gerne vor allem und das
ist wie ich
und auch ein bisschen percussion und
gitarre kann ihre begriffe
insofern war musik immer
teil meines lebens und wird es auch
bleiben also es hätte auch sagen können
dass ich musiker geworden wären oder bin
eigentlich immer musiker gewesen
das hat sich nur halt eben auf die
stimme beschränkt das konnte ich immer
am besten spielen stimmband
und das ist auch okay ich habe da auch
wirklich da die beste ausbildung sind
aus mitschülern vier jahre lang eine
klassische stimmausbildung und das kommt
natürlich gerade bei konzerten mit der
musik die ich mache sehr zugute weil ich
kann wirklich 23 stunden durch grünen
laut und kräftig ohne dass die stimme
danach kaputt ist oder häusern und das
kann ich am nächsten tag darauf auch
gleich wieder also das ist schon von
vorteil singen sie sich ein vorher
absolut ja dass so eine halbe stunde
ungefähr das ist wie mit allem mit wenn
man sport treibt die muskeln sollten
warmes einsatz verletzt man diene das
mit den stimmbändern genauso also wenn
die nicht eingegangen sind und nicht
geschmiert sind sozusagen dann kann
schon leicht sein dass man die mal kurz
falsch belastet also was auch ein guter
tipp ist wenn man nicht so gut bei
stimme ist oder wenn man heißer ist ein
apfel sehr gute apfelsäure da die da
drin ist ist sehr gut oder stück ingwer
auch gut
wunderbar dass mich
bei der platte
beeindruckt hat oder was mir aufgefallen
ist hauptsache beeindruckt das ist schon
mal sehr gut beeindruckt hat es sind
ganz man ist es nicht ein einfluss es
hört sich nicht an wie sondern sind
immer mal wieder da was zu hören und da
was zu hören also ich habe zum beispiel
john cale raus gehört ja ja ist der da
drin oder ist es jetzt mein persönlicher
eindruck dass der persönliche eindruck
der aber nicht falsch sein muss deswegen
es sind tatsächlich und also je öfter
ich das höre denke auch es ist ein
echtes kunststückchen gelungen
es sind einfach die stille dem ich im
laufe der jahrzehnte geprägt haben wohl
da eingeflossen mehr oder weniger
bewussten also ich wollte jetzt keine
sorgen muss songschreiben wo man sagt
das muss ich jetzt jj cale oder nach
queens clearwater revival oder nach
james brown anhören aber anscheinend
hört man doch immer mal das eine oder
andere raus und das ist auch richtig so
und so soll es auch sein ohne dass es
bewusst angelegt ist so bewusst ist es
nicht angelegt es ist schon in dem sie
den bewusst angelegt dass man sagt ich
möchte etwas machen was was mir einfach
gefällt wird sich selbst gerne anhören
würde und klar das spiegelt immer
geschmack wieder dass das hören sie
alles möglich also ich habe auf meinem
ipod 10.000 songs das ist noch der alte
mittlerweile gibt es ja ganz andere
geräte
aber ich komme eben aus der generation
obwohl man die kritik pflegt hat ja
ich habe von reggae salsa hip hop
jazz klassik alles alles mögliche drauf
und genießt es ja das ist
klasse ich mache das immer so auf zufall
na ja bei 10 3 songs wie harvard
historiker da kommt ein reggae song
danach kommt irgendwie etta james und
dann kommt carmina burana ja unter
umständen oder wagner oder irgendwann
kommt wie buena vista social club ist so
spannend immer ein kleiner bunter tücher
dabei aber das kann schon ein heftiges
kontrastprogramm sei also aber das ist
doch interessant dann irgendwie was für
verschiedene tolle musikrichtung
überhaupt gibt bei mir ist das problem
meine töchter laden auch musik drauf
das kann das keiner richtig
kontrastreich sein ist es bei ihnen auch
so dass sie eine musiksammlung zusammen
nutzen oder hat jeder in der familie die
eine andere musik sammlung na ja meine
kommt keiner
das kommt oft genug vor dass man sich
cds aus leid ich auch noch habe und ich
die vergeblich suchen ja kommt vor die
wende weiter gelesen ja
schon lustig sollte familien haben die
ähnlichen musikgeschmack
ja ja doch also ich meine ich wäre bei
der neueren musicals eigentlich immer
wieder die alte musik raus es ist aber
ich finde interessant welche
kombinationen zustande kommen also ich
höre auch die neuen sachen wie queens of
the stone age dirt und so gesagt habe
ich mal gehört was ist so auch keine
töchter jungs muss er so ok sie ziehen
jetzt von münchen nach berlin habe
gelesen ja da wissen sie mehr als ich
das glaube ich nicht was muss alles
liest meine söhne haben irgendwann mal
in der ju gesagt es ist nach berlin
ziehen würden weil jetzt großen film
gedreht haben und
so ist das entstanden
und ich habe mal gesagt überhaupt gut
kann ich mir vorstellen aber das in die
würfel noch lange nicht gefallen also
ich wollen in münchen bleiben schauen
wir mal also wir spielen mal mit dem
gedanken dann muss man aber viel vieles
durchdenken obwohl ich gelesen habe dass
sie ich habe es auch nur gelesen weil es
vielleicht wieder mehr als sie sollen
richtige zeitungen lesen dass es werden
verschlafen das nächste treffen sie
gesagt ja also
münchen ist ich habe 30 jahre gelebt und
sehr gern das sonst wäre ich gar nicht
so lange da geblieben
und es ist ein verschlafenes nest aber
das hat ja kann ja auch einen charme
haben kann ja auch könnte und es ist
gemütlich und alles wunderbaren alles
schön nur ich möchte auch noch ein
bisschen ins leben springen also ich
meine das weiß doch jeder aber das
männchen zur beleidigt ist gleich das
ist nun wie das doch bisschen der
pflichten aber dass auf der einen seite
fühle ich mich auch immer geschmeichelt
dass man was für ein gericht das hat
wenn man irgendwie sowas unwichtiges
angesagt aber
nichts gegen münchen es ist eine
wunderschöne stadt also zu mal weniger
ernst ich habe ich das ja wohl gefühlt
und tut das immer noch aber
berlin ist nun mal so und da kann in
münchen machen was es will es ist nun
mal eine große
welt stadt geworden und entwickelt sich
immer mehr in die richtung das hat auch
vor und nachteile deswegen ist uns noch
gar nicht so klar wie dahin sehen das
muss man also richtig durch denken das
ist ja doch mit aktionen verbunden das
hat er in berlin dass münchen nicht hat
es hat einfach es ist der stete
anziehungspunkt international
von der ganzen welt und es ist die
hauptstadt
allein aus dem grunde spielt sich schon
sehr viel ab es gibt halt dadurch dass
die stadt größer ist gibt es viel mehr
angebote in allen richtungen ja und
ich habe in so einer großen stadt noch
nie gelebt auch und es darf auch mal
ausprobieren oder es ist aber kalt es
ist kalt aber in münchen kann im winter
nun
aber in berlins dieses continental weiß
jetzt schon dass ich die weißwurst und
weißbier vermissen werde und die
biergärten aber es ist ja schön auch da
mal zu besuch zu kommen jetzt schauen
wir mal es ist noch lange nicht
irgendwie gegessen wann kommen denn die
umzugswagen weil ich muss ja immer
überlegen wenn ich jetzt im moment
münchen verlasse unter freis blind ob
ich überhaupt wieder einreisen darf nun
ja
wenn sie wahrscheinlich letzte mal die
haben sie irgendwie so so b-promis
gefragt nennt kommentar abzugeben was
sie davon halten stehen die gar nicht
erkennt hier kein schwein aber ist
natürlich eine gute chance mal wieder in
die zeitung zu kommen und man die
öffentlichkeit treten gab sollen zu
haben
wann kommt denn die umzugswagen ich weiß
es noch nicht
also sie sind der erste der sein pferd
okay ich glaube ihm kein wort
jetzt manchmal ganz gut so
man beobachtet ja so drang auch gerade
von von schauspieler
ehrlichen tut so als ich meint gerhard
polt sagt ich ziehe nach berlin und
münchen ist ein verschlafenes nest dann
kann ich verstehen wenn sich die
münchner aufregung bei mir ist völlig wo
ich glaube nicht dass mich irgendwer
vermissen dich doch wenn man 30 jahre
wohnt ja wenn dann vermisse ich münchen
okay das wird auch so sein ja aber
sie würden so was herz bringen
also vielleicht noch nicht und dann
sehen wir schon
bleibt spannend
aber sie beobachten auch dass immer mehr
schauspieler nach berlin ziehen dass das
ist ja
eher witzigerweise habe ich mittlerweile
fast schon mehr bekannte und freunde in
berlin also in münchen
ja und da sind halt um jeden der das
nachmacht wahrscheinlich bange muss ja
nicht gleich so böse reagieren so das
ziel noch mehr weg
ja ja es scheint ja auch ein richtiges
sich schon mal in berlin gibt es
inzwischen in anführungszeichen
gesellschaftliche ereignisse so was gab
es da ja vorher nicht
ganz früher schon ja ja ganz ganz früh
aber das ist schon da können wir uns
kaum daran erinnern
so ist das gibt's ja noch was wichtig
ist das fand ich jetzt unglaublich
wieder merkt gerade ja ja doch doch
einzigen andere auf dem herzen deutsches
fernsehen
ja es liegt noch sehr am herzen
ich versuche da zu verbessern dauert es
gelingt mir auch nicht immer aber ja da
könnte schon ein bisschen was tun also
und ja also ich das so sagen was ich sie
finden sich ja nicht so toll na ja es
ist natürlich man muss natürlich
aufpassen dass das dieser quoten hype
nicht überhand nimmt also dass es ist ja
nicht so dass es nur schlecht ist es
gibt absolute highlights zwischendrin
aber
man darf die zuschauer auch nicht so für
dumm verkauft die können schon ganz
schön beurteilen was qualität ist und
was nicht
und es gibt ja durchaus gute sachen aber
es könnte ein bisschen mehr davon seien
finde ich was können sie dazu beitragen
oder das wollen sie dazu beitragen
durch meine arbeit leben irgendwie
versuchen das niveau zu halten aber man
ist ja schon gezogen wenn man gerade bei
atommacht da muss man ja überall hin ob
es schlecht ist oder wird es aber man
muss gar nicht wenn man die pr wird
macht da kann man sich auch sein wo man
die besseren sachen raussuchen
qualitativ besser und sachen und
natürlich dann so
wunderbar vielen dank
gang